in a new video message president trump
is finally condemning the violence at
the u.s capitol and admitting he is
leaving office
but it must be said that that is only
after months and even
years of stoking the anger that exploded
in this week's attack
ben tracy is at the white house for us
this morning ben good morning to you
tony good morning so the president is
attempting a complete 180 here
on wednesday he called members of this
violent mob attacking the capital
special people now faced with
resignations from top
administration officials and the threat
of being impeached again
he says he's outraged by the violence
the demonstrators who infiltrated the
capitol
have defiled the seat of american
democracy
in a video produced by the white house
president trump last night finally
condemned the violence carried out in
his name
you do not represent our country but
this
is what the president said the day
before we love you
you're very special and what he said at
his rally before the assault on the
capitol
may be investigated by u.s attorneys for
leading to the violence
we're going to walk down to the capitol
and we're going to cheer on our brave
senators and congressmen and women
and we're probably not going to be
cheering so much for
some of them the president is also now
falsely claiming he immediately
deployed the national guard to stop the
attack on the capitol
he did not the violence went on for
hours
and the guard only arrived after vice
president mike pence got involved
mr pence who the president is attacking
for not trying to change the election
result
did not come to the white house thursday
cbs news has learned the two men
are barely speaking to each other at
least seven
white house officials have now resigned
in protest plus two members of the
cabinet
education secretary betsy devos and
secretary of transportation elaine chao
she is married to senate majority leader
mitch mcconnell and former attorney
general bill barr who left the
administration just last month
delivered a blistering rebuke saying in
a statement that orchestrating a mob to
pressure congress is inexcusable
and calling the president's conduct a
betrayal of his office
a new administration will be inaugurated
on january 20th
president trump appears to finally be
resigned to the fact
after two months that president-elect
biden will be sworn in
after misleading his supporters about
false allegations
that the election was stolen my focus
now turns to ensuring a smooth orderly
and seamless transition of power
some of the president's usual allies
want him to resign
before inauguration day the conservative
editorial board of the wall street
journal which is owned by rupert murdoch
says his best path would be to take
personal responsibility and resign
adding it is best for everyone himself
included
if he goes away quietly the president
has given no indication he intends to
resign
or go away quietly anthony yeah and he
still has not conceded that he lost ben
thank you very much